welcome to exploring computing
today's video is additional python
features
so in this video we're going to take a
look at a few other
python language features that you might
find handy
in certain situations so the first one i
wanted to talk about is how to do a
multi-line statement
so sometimes you have a line of code
that's just too long to fit on
a single line comfortably and in some
languages you can just go ahead and
split
across the line you can just say oh this
doesn't fit on the line
i'm going to go ahead and put a
character turn in the middle uh
the language interpreter should figure
this out and it turns out this does not
work in python so
if you do what i've done here where i've
taken name equals and i put in a
character term there and then i followed
on the next line with input
this is actually going to cause an error
when you try and load it so
that's no good so there's uh several
solutions to this
um the one that's universally going to
be
doable is you can go ahead and put a
backslash at the end of your unfinished
line so if i say name equals
and then i have that backslash don't use
the forward slash gotta be backslash got
that backslash
that tells python i'm not really done
with the line
uh go to the next line that's actually a
continuation of the current line
in addition you can use parentheses so
uh if you've already got parentheses
you've got like that input statement
there i can go ahead and use the
parenthesis for the input statement
um you can also in in many situations
like if you've got a mathematical format
you can just put in parentheses wherever
you want
but if you've got an open parenthesis
like here where i've got that input
and then open parentheses python
immediately realizes that
it doesn't see a closing parenthesis on
that current line so
i must be spreading my statement across
multiple lines and it will go ahead and
continue processing lines the subsequent
lines as if they were part of the
original line until it sees that closing
parentheses
you can do the same thing with the
square brackets so if you've got a list
of items like
you've got here um it sees that opening
square bracket
it sees a bunch of people on our team
member list it doesn't see a closing
square bracket it says oh
uh you must want me to continue
processing uh the next line and the next
line until i see that closing
angular bracket
all right another issue that sometimes
comes up is how to
do what's called concatenating strings
and computer science concatenating
strings means to combine two strings
into a single string
and there's a variety of different ways
to do this depending upon the
programming language
in python you just separate the strings
by space
and it automatically puts them together
so i say hello
space everyone it's going to combine
that together into a single string hello
everyone notice that it does not
actually add a space into the hello
everyone so
again hello everyone so if you want a
space either the hello string needs to
end with the space or the everyone
string needs to start with a space or
you need to put in a third
in the middle a quote with a space with
a closing quote
in between the hello and the everyone
and that will combine to get you hello
space everyone
this can be useful when we have a really
long string so
here i'm using the stamp for motto i'm
not going to attempt to read it i don't
know german at all
the stanford motto blah blah blah
translates as the wind of freedom blows
and so maybe that's a little bit too
long to fit on a single line i want to
put it across multiple lines
and i'm going to do that by breaking it
down into individual strings
notice each of these strings at least
the first
three strings ends with a space so
translates as
space the stand for motto space
dash space because remember if we don't
put those spaces in there
when these this string gets combined
back together uh
we're not going to have spaces so don't
forget your spaces
you may also notice that i don't have
closing uh
backslashes on the end of each of these
lines and that's because i've got that
print statement so i've got the print
parentheses and so that immediately
tells
python that it should continue
processing each of the following lines
as if they were on the same line
until it hits that closing parenthesis
you can also use triple quotes for this
so if you've got a
long string and you
don't want to bother putting quotes
around all of them and you want it to go
across multiple lines
um you can just put a triple quote at
the start and then a triple quote at the
end
and this will also work
okay the last thing i wanted to mention
in our short little video on additional
python features is
how you write a comment in python and so
you'll recall that
a comment is used when we want to convey
information to other humans who are
reading our code but
we want it to be ignored by the computer
so here
the number sign is used by python and
when
for comments and when python sees the
number sign
it ignores everything following the
number sign until the end of the line
that's considered a comment that's the
python thinks oh that's something for
human beings i'm not a human being so
i'm going to go ahead and ignore it
here we've got a number sign defined
variable
so that whole line it starts with the
number sign so that whole line is just
going to get completely ignored by the
computer computer's just going to be
like
oh this must be something that patrick
wants for other people reading the code
to know but
i'm not a person i'm a computer i'm
better than a person i'm a computer
so i'm going to just ignore that line so
it completely ignores that first line
and then the next line
total equals 0 number sign total number
of students is initially zero
it is going to process the total equals
zero that's not behind a number sign but
then as soon as it sees that number
science says
uh the rest of this line that's for
humans i'm going to go ignore it so this
whole thing
number sign defined variables total
equals zero number sign
total number of students is initially
zero is going to get treated by the
computer as just
total equals zero all right that's it
for today we've got one more lecture on
uh on python programming i'll see you
soon